>> Mark: A PROBE ALL YOU CAN
PROBE BUFFET.
RATHER THAN LEGISLATE BOTH
PARTIES IN WASHINGTON WANT TO
VELS THE MISDEEDS OF THE OTHER.
JUST A FEW WEEKS LEFT OF THEIR
MAJORITY, HOUSE REPUBLICANS WANT
TO HOLD HEARINGS ON THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION.
MEANWHILE, DEMOCRATS NOW WANT A
NEW INVESTIGATION LOOKING AGENT
IVANKA TRUMP'S USE OF A PRIVATE
E-MAIL TO CARRY OUT GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS.
THEY WANT TO EQUATE IVANKA TO
HILLARY CLINTON AND HER PRIVATE
SERVER.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THERE'S NO
COMPARISON.
>> President Trump: IVANKA CAN
HANDLE HERSELF.
THESE ARE ALL IN THE HISTORICAL
RECORDS, THERE WAS NO DELETION
WHATSOEVER, UNLIKE HILLARY
CLINTON WHO DELETED 33,000
E-MAILS.
UNLIKE HILLARY CLINTON WHO HAD A
SERVER IN THE BASEMENT, IVANKA
DIDN'T.
THIS IS JUST EARLY ON, WHEN SHE
CAME IN.
SHE IS CALLS WERE NOT
CLASSIFIED, UNLIKE HILLARY
CLINTON'S CALLS WHICH WERE
CLASSIFIED.
AND IT'S ALL FAKE NEWS.
>> Mark: THE PRESIDENT BEFORE
HIS THANKSGIVING BREAK.
BRIAN DEAN WRIGHT IS A DEMOCRAT
AND FORMER CIA OFFICER.
BRIAN, WE HAVE CAUGHT HOUSES
LEGISLATING AND LEGISLATORS
HOLDING TROIL.
IS THIS THE BEST USE FOR
CONGRESS?
>> OH, WE HAVE TWO YEARS OF
THIS, BROTHER.
I HOPE WE'RE ALL READY.
THE SHORT ANSWER IS NO, THERE'S
A SMALL DEGREE OF OVERSIGHT THAT
IS CRITICAL, TO THE SENATE AND
THE HOUSE.
WHETHER IT'S LOOKING INTO THE
HILLARY CLINTON FOUNDATION, BILL
AND HILLARY CLINTON FOUNDATION,
THE SHENANIGANS, LET THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WRAP IT
UP.
ON THE I SKRA.
>>CA SIDE, MAKE SURE SHE DIDN'T
SEND ANYTHING CLASSIFIED.
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE REALLY CARE
ABOUT IVANKA'S E-MAILS ABSENT
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
I'LL SAY NONE.
I'M IN NORTHERN INDIANA, THE
PEOPLE IN FORT WAYNE, PLACES
LIKE HUNTINGTON, AREN'T
CONCERNED WITH IVANKA'S E-MAILS.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO
GOVERN, BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED IN ALL OF THAT
SILLINESS.
WHAT DO THEY WANT, THEY WANT
CONGRESS TO FOCUS ON THE STUFF
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO FOCUS ON.
JOBS, HAISHG.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT
AMERICA CARES ABOUT.
>> Mark: YOU AREN'T GOING TO GET
ANYWHERE ON THAT, ARE YOU, THE
ENERGY IN THE NEW DEMOCRAT
CONGRESS IS FOR, WELL FOR A
START THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
AND IF THEY CAN'T IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, THEY AT LEAST WOULD
LIKE TO ENSNARE THOSE AROUND HIM
SUCH AS MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY,
AND TEDIOUS INVESTIGATIONS, FOR
A COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> SURE, WE'VE SEEN THIS, THE
20-PLUS YEARS, WHAT HAS AMERICA
EXPERIENCED?
ONE SIDE TRYING TO MESS OVER THE
OTHER WITH THE HOPE THEY CAN
GAIN GREATER POWER IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN
CERTAINLY IN 2016, THE DEGREE IN
THE LAST FEW WEEKS, PEOPLE
WALKING IN TO THE VOTING BOOTH,
AND USING THEIR MIDDLE FINGER TO
VOTE AND SAYING ENOUGH.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE BUSINESS
OF GOVERNING.
AND I THINK MOST PEOPLE ARE SO
US FROM FREIGHTED ABOUT THE BACK
AND FORTH OF NOT SOLVING
PROBLEMS.
HUNTINGTON, GIVE YOU A GREAT
EXAMPLE, THE CARRIER COMPANY
SHUT DOWN AND LAID OFF A BUNCH
OF FOLKS R THEY CARING ABOUT
IVANKA'S E-MAILS?
NO, THEY'RE NOT.
THEY WANT TO SOLVE THIS AS
GLOBAL TRADE ISSUE, WHERE THINGS
GET SHIPPED OFF TO MEXICO OR
CHINA.
THAT'S THE STUFF THAT PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT.
GOOD HEALTHCARE.
SO IF PEOPLE DON'T GET THE
RESULTS THEY WANT, EITHER FROM
THE LAST ELECTION WITH DEMOCRATS
WINNING OR PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
HIS PROMISES OF 2016, PARTIES
ARE GOING TO PAY FOR IT,
SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY FOR IT.
YOU WATCH, THEY WILL.
>> Mark: IS THERE A SERIOUS
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM HERE, THE
DEMOCRATS PARTICULARLY, BUT YOU
COULD MAKE POINTS ABOUT BOTH
SIDES ON THIS.
IN EFFECT, THE CRIMINALIZATION
OF POLITICS F YOU HAVE A
PARTICULAR APPROACH TO
IMMIGRATION, OR HEALTHCARE, OR
WHATEVER IT IS, IT'S NOT JUST
THAT YOU HAVE A PUBLIC POLICY
DIFFERENCE.
IT'S THAT IN SOME SENSE ARE YOU
A CRIMINAL AND YOU HAVE TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
>> RIGHT.
WELL, WHEN YOU SEE THE OTHER
SIDE AS EVIL, THAT'S WHEN YOU
START GETTING THIS INVESTIGATIVE
JUNK.
AND SO WE HAVE TO CHANGE THAT
WITH OUR OWN HEARTS.
DEFINITELY WHEN WE GO TO THE
VOTING BOOTH, WE HAVE TO FORWARD
PROSPECT OF FOLKS IN THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM WHO ARE MORE
INTERESTED IN SOLVING PROBLEMS
AND NOT SEEING THE OTHER SIDE AS
EVIL.
THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.